listen I have to start with the most
important question UPF front um when did
you decide that you would only play race
car
[Laughter]
[Music]
drivers I I didn't it was just a huge
coincidence yeah I mean well what's
interesting is these are both incredible
people incredible stories and I mean you
can't say no to either role but like it
is weird definitely yeah and uh it
happened almost
simultaneously I did the the tape for
Ferrari I did probably July or June end
of June and I got the part and I did the
Santa tape July and I got the part I got
I heard the news when I was there in mod
prepping for Ferrari so it was it
happened simultaneously I I knew that I
would be playing racing drivers for more
than a year and a half right uh jumping
into Ferrari you're playing someone who
is obviously you're playing a real
person so as an actor how much are you
like in the preparation process trying
to learn everything you can but at the
same time you know this is like um uh
it's not a literal translation you know
what I mean yeah of course and because
the movie wasn't about him of course so
and uh we didn't have much uh uh
information about the Pago I did me and
Michael we did the most we could uh to
research to to find information about
him I found this book I found this old
vinyl of him giving interview we had the
photos um but most of all uh Michael
wanted me to find his personality he was
a Playboy of his time he was also a
sportsman he was a noble he was a
marquee from Spain so that's what we
looked for uh during prep was to find
this energy uh and also there was like a
mission to to to Brando style and energy
so I did some research of course we
watched some early brle Bros movies so
that was it I am a huge Michael Man Fan
I would imagine you are as well what
surprised you about working with him
that you didn't expect going in for me
it was kind of a dream I've also I've
always been a huge fan of him too of his
movies and to have the first experience
out of Brazil shooting acting English to
be directed by him and I mean to be on
scene with Adam was unbelievable for me
I learned so much from them
and I have a a cool story with Michael
um my dad watched it last the micans
with me when I was a kid and the first
time my dad went to Europe was last year
in Italy I took him to the set he
visited the set he watched Michael
directing me and then I introduced
themselves and it was like a full circle
for me um a pretty an amazing moment I
have so I'm very thankful for Michael
for for it all not not only for the
opportunity to be on this movie but I
mean to have to have the the whole
experience yeah I can't even imagine um
I'm definitely curious you so you're
filming the racing scenes in this and
obviously you filmed racing scenes in
Senna um did I pronounce that right
Senna Santa perfectly okay just making
sure how do the um racing scenes in both
projects how are they similar and how
are they different on Ferrari Michael
wanted us
to we shot all the scenes on the Real
Track like some of them some of them I
was driving some of them I was uh on the
camera camera car
um uh on Santa we've been we had also
the stun drivers that shot we had like a
performance Unity shooting uh separately
from us and we used U LED Studio to
shoot all of the close-ups because we
had like loads it's a six episode series
for Netflix so we have loads of of of uh
racing scenes since his early years for
formula 4 uh Formula 3 to Formula 1 um
so that's the the difference between
both projects Michael really shot on the
real track most of it and Santa would
use for the close-ups uh the LED Studio
yeah I don't think and I know I have to
go but I don't think people realize how
big of a star he is in Brazil and to to
the racing Community for people that
don't know I mean he's the Brad Pit kind
of yeah I'd say he's even more because
he's one of the biggest if not the
biggest Idol from Brazil not only for
from sport it's like uh for any
Brazilian sen is like a yeah it's our
biggest idle I'd say thank you so much
congrats on this looking forward to
talking to you again when I've seen the
series thank
you